hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and as I'm recording these words
we are in the middle of proto pandemic
with the coronavirus the Cova Dean
disease that is happening because of
this I am certainly not an expert in
viruses or pandemics or anything like
that and this episode is not about
viruses or pandemics but it is about
evolution and you know this is part of
why we get pandemics is because all
these little microbes bless their hearts
they keep evolving clever new ways to
deal with us even if it hurts us in
doing it and it turns out when you go
into the details that we human beings
sometimes take advantage like as you'll
learn in this podcast human DNA has a
certain fraction that is just borrowed
wholesale from virus DNA in cases where
we encountered a virus and we didn't
just combat it we absorbed it or at
least absorbed part of it it's part of
the whole question of how transitions
happen in evolution you know when
Charles Darwin first invented the idea
of natural selection he had the idea
that it was more or less gradual right
that there were slow changes minor
changes and some of them would catch on
develop and grow others would be less
successful but we do see examples of
major transitions whether they happen
quickly or not it's a complicated thing
but there are transitions like the first
flight right you know the first animals
that could actually fly and develop
wings or the first climbing on to land
on the part of aquatic animals so this
has always been a question for Darwinian
evolution how does that happen how does
a fish develop the right organismal
abilities to live on and flourish on dry
land
like it's not teleological if the
evolution is not based on goals toward
future success so the fish can't think
to itself I would like to be able to get
up and get that yummy food up on land
let me develop some feet and some lungs
and and the ability to do that so today
we're talking to Neil Shubin who is a
quite well known evolutionary biologist
he is
a distinguished service professor of
organismal biology and anatomy at the
University of Chicago very well known of
course for being one of the co
discoverers of Tiktaalik the fossil that
represents a crucially important
transitional stage the transitional
stage precisely from being a fish
swimming in the water to being amphibian
living mostly on land it's a little fish
like thing that has the basic very
primitive versions of feet and hands and
the ability to breathe air and so forth
so Neil has some evolution of his own in
the research that he does mostly from
going out there and hunting fossils and
doing paleontology and learning about
the evolution of life on that macro
scale to being in a lab and doing
molecular biology understanding how
changes in DNA both the actual coding
for proteins but also how the DNA we
have is regulated and expressed can lead
to these major transitions in evolution
I mean what actually happens in the DNA
of a fish to turn it into something that
can climb about on land it's an
extremely exciting field because it's
one of these things where obviously
we've learned a lot but there's still a
lot left to learn
and as we discussed at the very end of
the episode it's a rapidly changing
field in part because we are developing
the ability to make these changes in DNA
ourselves so what used to be more or
less gradual changes in how organisms
functioned can be very very rapid
because now we can have teleology we can
actually plan what might not happen next
so it's a fun episode Neil as a
wonderful science communicator he's the
author of a book called your inner fish
which tells how things that are still in
your body right now or first developed
in the context of when our ancestors
were in fact fish and he has a new book
coming out literally tomorrow as this
episode is being released called some
assembly required
decoding four billion years of life from
ancient fossils to DNA about these major
transitions in evolution and how we are
learning about them through studying DNA
so let's go
[Music]
Neil Shubin welcome to the lionsgate
podcast well great to be here we're
gonna be talking about evolution natural
selection Charles Darwin I want to let
everyone know right from the start
official mindscape podcast position is
that evolution is real and we're you
know really happy we're not going to be
discussing whether or not evolution
happened versus creationism or anything
like that I hope that's okay with you
yeah I didn't do that in the book either
so that's good yeah that's not why we're
here you go other places for that but
given that evolution is real given the
Darwin was roughly speaking right
there's certainly a lot of work to be
done right and figuring out exactly how
it happened is that is that a fair way
of stating it and that's good news
because that keeps people like me
employed I mean there are three cently
it's just we've had game-changing
technologies both over the ways we
analyze fossils but in molecular biology
and computation that really changed
things you know and so so many of the
questions that Darwin had and many of
the ideas he had are still relevant but
boy are we learning new things yeah yeah
and it's always you know one of those
things where when you solve one problem
you open up multiple new problems right
and multiple new puzzles and I think
that people who are not embedded in the
scientific process might feel like
there's just more and more puzzles than
you guys have inventing whereas it's
actually you know there's more and more
knowledge being gained at the same time
yeah you know sometimes you actually get
to ants ask new kinds of questions more
powerful questions in many ways more
precise questions maybe more global
questions so you know it's so the
questions never stop they just change
and we as we gain answers we gain new
questions yeah so we have you have a new
book coming out called some assembly
required decoding four billion years of
life from ancient fossils to DNA
congratulations on that oh thank you so
much and you've you've written a couple
of other books you know you're the your
sort of break out one was your inner
fish about the discovery of I always say
teak to leek but I'm totally that's not
the wrong pronunciation right well
that's actually right in some quarters
but we say Tiktaalik Tiktaalik okay yeah
so if you go to the Inuit it's just an
Inuit word and then you a name it would
they would be ticked like oh really
tick buddy likes tiktaalik is what we've
been saying yeah oh I'm definitely going
to
so we'll tell that story a little bit
but first just to you know put things in
context one of the things that you still
want to understand if you're a good
natural selection evolutionary biologist
is the question of missing links and big
transitions in evolution right I mean
the joke is that whenever you find a
missing link you've created two more
missing links because you now have you
know one species in between two other
ones but this is a good puzzle for
biology is that right oh it's a
wonderful one in fact it's the one that
drew me into the field and in realizing
that that's how this book came about was
realizing how important those questions
are the great transitions in evolution
and some of the misconceptions that we
have all of us about those transitions
missing links being one of them so what
sense is is there a slogan that says the
idea of missing links is itself a
misconception well there should be as
somebody who's been you knows claimed to
have found a missing link other people
have reported that that Tiktaalik is but
the reality is evolution is you know
it's a hugely branching tree it doesn't
take a straight on path and you know
when we talk about links which there are
number one they're found they're not
missing but number two you know the the
path of evolution is often very
unpredictable it has lots of twists and
turns and and goes backwards and
forwards and it's it's it's not a
straight path a linear ladder it's a
hugely branching Bush of change that you
know that goes in many different
directions so that the missing link
concept I mean the part of it that's
right is link is there are links among
species but but what underlies that
narrative however is the assumption that
evolution acts as a ladder of progress
of change of one form inexorably giving
rise to another that's you know that
looks sort of like that looks the same
but different there are aspects of that
that are true but it's that linear
narrative that that I think we're
finding as we study fossils and genes
this really doesn't hold up yeah and
your book certainly does a good job of
explaining the messiness of it all which
is which is you know like you say full
employment for scientists
so that's beautiful messiness though
there's the mess is the message you know
and so we can get into that but it's a
that's half the fun of this you know so
but that's why people should become
physicist
instead of biologists it's way cleaner
so one of the very most obvious links
that one might want to fill in whether
you call it a missing link or not is
between fish and land dwellers or
amphibians or whatever and that's where
Tiktaalik comes into the story so why
don't you tell us just a wonderful human
story of you and your team discovering
that and what it all meant well it began
as I described in the book actually it
began in my second year graduate school
I was - I didn't know what I wanted to
do for my PhD I knew I wanted to study
evolution but I thought maybe I want to
study mammals or I don't know I didn't
know and so I took a survey course on
evolution and like each week was a
different greatest hits in the history
of life you know you go from one great
transition to the next and the professor
showed this beautiful slide of a fish
and on one end and an amphibian a
tetrapod a limb Danimal on the other
with an arrow connecting them and it was
like kind of what we knew about that
transition from water to land and I
remember looking at that slide thinking
golly I want to work on that problem and
I want to find fossils that do it and so
you know with colleagues we set off on a
multi-year quest to find an intermediate
between a fish that lives in water in an
alumna animal tetrapod that lives on
land and we know we used the rules of
paleontology you know we didn't invent
new methods here we were using sort of
the tried-and-true
you know perspectives of field
paleontology which go as follows in
simplified form if you want to find a in
a key intermediate fossil say a
transitional fossil say between say fish
and tetrapods or between you know birds
and reptiles or reptiles mammals
whatever you know you look for places in
the world that have three things you
look for places in the world that have
rocks that hold rocks of the right age
to answer whatever question interests
you you know so if you're interested in
the fish - limbed animal transition
you're gonna look in rocks about 380 375
million years old or so you'd look for
places in the world that have rocks of
the right type to hold fossils obviously
not every kind of rock does that and as
a geologist you start to learn to
catalogue of environments and rocks that
are likely to preserve the best fossils
that's as much art as science by the way
and a lot of induction there and then
the third part is you look for place
in the world that now I have rocks to
the right age when there I type but the
rocks that are exposed and accessible
you know makes total sense right yeah
you don't want rocks that are buried 12
miles underground or there that are in
the side of Mount Everest you are in a
politically enviable place a war zone
you know you need accessibility and so
those are the filters right so you know
with that last one being that you know
erosion and plate tectonics etcetera are
constantly exposing new layers and so
you're gonna go for look for layers
which have the kind of rocks that you
want that's correct that's correct and
so you can actually go to geological
archeology libraries which is what we
did in the 90s or do it online and you
get aerial photos you can get geological
maps that give you the kinds of rocks in
a country's border you can dig out
papers on the local geology to find out
what kind of rocks are there and you can
put all this informations together so
that's what we're doing in the 90s we
you know looking for rocks to the right
age about 375 million years old and so
forth
our first gig was in Pennsylvania cuz I
my first job was outside Phil it was it
was in University of Pennsylvania in
Philadelphia and I and I grew up there
as well and so I you know I knew the
place and I also knew that there was a
lot of Devonian age rock in Pennsylvania
throughout the state so it became our
for the first part of our hunt was
looking at the Devonian age again 365 to
375 million year old rocks and in
Pennsylvania and turns out we you know
we'd have a lot of exposures so we
worked on road cuts you know when
PennDOT Pennsylvania Department of
Transportation would come in to build a
new road we'd you know we'd get in there
and and look at the rocks and that was
amazingly successful it really was we
you know we started to find early
tetrapods early limbed animals we found
all kinds of fish it was just a
remarkably productive program but my
colleague in this Ted daeschler was a
student at the time and now I know a
colleague who works on all this stuff
with me we've always made a problem we
were in rocks that were too young to
answer the question we wanted to find a
fish with limb you know with a fin with
limb bones inside it that had a head
like a tetrapod like a flat head not a
conical head like a fish that had a neck
or things like that and we weren't
finding a lot of that so we were rocks
are way too young to answer the question
so back to the drawing board and so it
turned out one thing led to another and
we settled on
in a region of a rock up in the Canadian
Arctic that extends from about 1500
kilometers from Melville Island in the
West to Ellesmere Island in the east and
perfect I mean Rock 375 million years
old rock that was produced in ancient
rivers and stream much like the Amazon
Delta today is in the Canadian Arctic by
the way that they'll sell different well
that much of the world's changed and
then rock that was exposed by ice and
water and so forth so we had all our
variables maximized at this spot so
starting in 1999 we we began expeditions
there and maybe more exotic than the
hills of Pennsylvania yeah quite a bit
you know you're you know taking a team
of six people there are polar bears up
there it's daylight 24 hours a day we're
300 miles from the nearest village which
is 170 people at 80 north latitude I
mean it is pretty extreme and for those
reasons that took us a while to be
successful I mean a season up there
would be about four weeks and so we
started 99 did four weeks then 2000 did
it again and each year we made a little
progress but we never really found what
we were looking for until 2004 we had
found a layer with lots of fish bones in
it and we were digging this layer I'll
never forget this day in my life it was
like July 17 2004 we're in this layer
cracking rocks finding fossils fish
nothing we'd be talking about but my
colleague one of my colleagues in the
pit with me cracked a rock and said hey
what's this I came over and I looked at
it and as soon as I saw that I knew we
had found what we had spent 6 years and
lots of money and lots of sprained
ankles looking for and what it was was
it was a snout of a fish clearly had
fishbone and the texture was classically
fish it was clearly the front of a skull
but it was clearly a very flat skull and
so early limbed animals have flat heads
we were looking for a flat headed fish
so I said here's a flat headed fish
looking right out at me in the rock
there's a lot of celebration so we ended
up removing the whole thing's about 4
feet long a little over a meter and then
pulled it out and then as we did that we
found four more of these things and
since then we found another 20 so
they're not at all rare and then we got
these things back to the lab
and they were rock was removed grain by
grain and you know first we saw it had a
thin great but then we saw inside it had
a humerus an upper arm bone had a radius
and ulna in there it had a wrist it had
even things that look like compared to
digits fingers and toes the most fish
don't have yeah and but in a fin clearly
had sin raised you know and this thing
clearly had a shoulder that was part
fish part limbed animal had that sort of
setup yet it had scales yet had fish
like bones in the skull so it was a real
you know mosaic between characteristics
of fish and limbed animal and it was an
animal that had lungs and gills it fins
with Lynn bones inside you know it's
exactly what we were looking for
and it tells us a lot about how this
transition from water to land happened
you know if it's real physical evidence
of that and it wasn't lost on us that
this was when we were working on this
fossil initially it was 2000 find it in
2004 we did most of the work in 2005 and
6 illustrating it there were trials
going on where people were you know
suing to teach intelligent design
creationism yes schools you know and
here we had on our desks these these
fossils it was quite the time I mean
presumably they would just say you know
yeah you glued together a fish with a
salamander or something like that
right I mean but we actually recorded us
taking it out I mean this was just and
the wonderful thing is that about this
example where I love using it to teach
not only because it's a huge part of my
life is that we used the tools of
evolutionary biology of geology and
stratigraphy of historical geology to
make a prediction right you know we
didn't go randomly to the Arctic you
know and we didn't just stay there and
we stayed there for six years we stayed
there for a reason is we had a we felt
we had a very strong prediction we that
the you know odds were in our favor if
we stuck with it long enough that we
would be successful and yeah and that's
that's what happened it's a predictive
science it's not merely a matter of
history that's correct and it's you know
you can you can put the odds in your
favor by knowing a lot about the
evolutionary history of the groups are
interested in the dating and ages that
those fossils first appear and then
knowing a lot about the environments the
creatures likely lived in once you do
that then you can make your predictions
and that's the toolkit
you've probably heard of peloton it's a
game changing home exercise system that
lets you do your cardio workout with a
bike right in the comfort of your very
own home and the best thing is that
right now there's a new 30-day home
trial that will let you try out the
peloton bike for yourself I've ridden it
I know what it's like and I can verify
that it's incredibly convenient and also
it kind of makes the exercise fun when
you have a bike at home you can just go
down ride it whenever you want morning
evening if you're not feeling up to it
you can skip it if you are feeling extra
energetic you can take advantage of that
peloton offers a variety of classes you
can take
led by instructors or just courses that
you can go through discover different
music playlists that will get you going
and so forth with the 30 day free trial
you can find your favorite classes you
can see whether you like it you can have
different profiles for everyone in your
household whoever they may be so try it
for yourself
learn more about peloton's 30-day home
trial at 1 peloton calm using promo code
mindscape that's o-n-e PL oto n.com code
mindscape to get started if you don't
find that the bike is right for you
they'll pick it up full refund worryfree
you sort of skipped over one thing which
i think is absolutely fascinating so
once you've found the Rox you want to
look at and then you go up there for
years on end what is the actual process
of looking through the rocks for a
fossil like like I mean I can imagine
I've been walking through rocks for a
long time and not see any fossils part
of it is just you have a trained eye but
there's probably more to it than that
well it's getting a trained eye
definitely there's there's a couple
things that fits together
one is you train your eye and if you
were to come on an expedition with us
you know you'd first get there and you
think we were magicians we'd be picking
up rocks all over your feet and but
after a few days you'd do it yourself
you know that that pattern recognition
system that we all have kicks in takes a
few days but you learn it and you know
and whenever I go to a new place I have
to learn how to find new fossils each
Rock kind of rock is different but what
we do is you know you get up in the
morning and we have geological maps we
have our aerial photos we have a good
knowledge of what kinds of
rocks are exposed everywhere around us
so which Hills hold which kinds of rocks
so we decide in the morning you know
which rocks we want to visit so we'll
walk to those and we'll literally follow
layers for miles looking for bones that
are weathering out on the surface and
it's just painstaking you got to stick
to it and once we find something that's
weathering then we'll you know if it
looks good we'll make you know we'll dig
out the layer try to find the layer the
fossils are coming from and if it's any
good we'll put a whole team on removing
the fossils in that layer that's
essentially what happens and so you know
success but what is six what matters
here
what matters is developing that eye
developing a knowledge of the geology of
the rocks you're working on being really
patient yeah there'll be whole days
whole weeks where you're not finding
stuff but you've got to stay on point
and sometimes that's not easy you know
if the weather is lousy if you know
you're stuck in the Arctic and you want
to get home I mean you know there's lots
of other psychological things that kick
in as well that you know you have to
think about up there but all those are
variables that luta that are related to
success well you know we've done the
experiment I have gone on to Wyoming and
Montana with your colleague Paul Sereno
digging for dinosaurs and I'm just not
really very good at distinguishing their
rocks from any well I got news I was no
good either when I wasn't ready the
first expedition I went on it was like
1983 my first year in graduate school I
was invited to like look for fossil
mammals which are really small I was an
utter disaster to the point where one of
the senior people told me like you know
you don't have a future that's kid by
the way I'd never camped before that you
know I was a nerd and so this all was
new but then I decided I wanted to do it
and just like anything in life we can
learn exactly and I love the fact that
the book that he wrote about this was
not just hey we found you know a
transitional organism between fish and
amphibians but the fact that the relics
of that transition are still within us
today right that's what it really means
to have our inner fish and it's oh yeah
and ER that the transitions are gradual
and continuous from very early times to
right now that's correct
I mean so the conceit
that book was you know though that
fossil was just a waypoint but really
when she start to look at anatomy and
development and molecular biology what
you start to see is there's billions of
years of artifacts of billions of years
of history inside our own bodies and you
see that in the genome you see that in
ourselves you see that in our tissues
our organs you know so whether you you
know you look at our skulls limbs and so
forth we can see
layer after layer of evolutionary
history inside of us so that was the
story that I told him in her fish and
you know that was a really an extension
of a lot of the teaching I did because
at the time I was also at the time we
discovered Tiktaalik I was I was
teaching human anatomy to medical
students here in Chicago Medical School
so I was like enabled me to connect the
dots in a way I probably wouldn't have
done in the same way I think that
hiccups were my fame favorite example
right can you explain why we have
hiccups yeah well we have hiccups you
know it's basically a spasm of the
phrenic nerve one theory that came out
of folks in Canada about a few years ago
was the idea that that that response
that's that is a very calibrated
stereotypical response of nerves firing
and muscles firing and a consequence
that there's a pattern inside the our
central nervous system that causes that
pattern to occur that pattern occurs
naturally elsewhere in the in the wild
in one place where we see it as in frogs
and tadpoles which have to you which use
a form of a hiccup and that neuro
response to actually breathe with with
water and so what we'll see is there's
these antecedents that we see in other
animals for for things that are you know
we think are distinctively human when in
reality they're not yeah so we can get
into exactly sort of the purpose I think
the main theme let's call it that of
this podcast which is this is the the
Tiktaalik does represent a major
transition from one way of life to
another can can you just say a little
bit for people who don't know anything
about you know what was its motivation
for climbing up onto land and how did
that really work I mean it seems like
something that if you're just underwater
and have a happy life there that
climbing up to a different poisonous
environment is not your first idea well
if it helps to compare water and land
and so there's probably there probably
many but if you look in the DeVoe
and what lived in the water at that time
you had big fish who had small fish but
pretty much all of them were carnivores
they were all predators so as a
fish-eat-fish world you know and by the
way you wouldn't wanted to swim in these
new in these Devonian streams there were
15 foot long predators filling the
crocodile continent giant predators with
teeth the size of railroad spikes you
know so yeah so it's a very predator and
competitor intense world in the water
but if you look at land at that time
there are there's there plants on land
there are invertebrates there are food
sources on land there are a few
competitors and certainly no predators
so you know anything that would serve
any trait that would allow a creature to
avoid that the water get away from the
Predators and the competitors into the
mudflats into land would probably be
favored because there was a world of
opportunity with foodstuffs on land
without competitors or predators there
are probably other reason lots of other
reasons as well you know things like
Tiktaalik and it's its cousins and in
the Devonian we're not fully land living
they were living in the in the shallows
and the mud flats yeah so there's a
continuum between these environments as
well so lots of reasons but those those
you know there's lots of good reasons to
get out of the water you know you could
think about it if if it's a
fish-eat-fish world you can there's lots
of strategies you can get big cuz big
fish eat little fish you can get armor
which a lot of fish do or you can get
out of the way I think our distant
ancestors were the ones who got out of
there but it's not Lamarckian you can't
as the fish say boy there's a lot of
yummy food up there on land I think I
will turn my fins into feet right I mean
that's exactly right that's a really
good point it's not that it's it's
actually it's natural selection and
that's what some assembly required the
new book really is about in showing how
that happens
so the it's you know when you think
about the water to land transition it's
actually exemplifies other great
transitions as well and showing one
really important thing that is pretty
much every trait that we associate with
one of the great revolutions in the
history of life say limbs or arms and
you know the invasion of land lungs in
the invasion Elad feathers in the origin
of flight you know walking on two legs
and the origin of
pretty much every trait that we
associate with the revolution is not
associate with that revolution it came
about millions of years before right you
know and that's the big thing you know
and one of the quotes that leads off the
book is one of my favorite ones from
Lillian Hellman who lived a fairly hard
life and she said you know nothing of
course ever begins when you think it
does and that is a great motto for
thinking about evolutionary change
you know nothing begins me it always
begins well before it's always only
purposing something else right it's
repurposing you know and it's
repurposing and modifying and then
repurposing again co-opting duplicating
merging I mean it's all these things
it's it's tinkering in in some very
profound ways and we get to see you know
glimpses of that tinkering in the fossil
record we could see the pathway it took
but when we look at genes and we look at
development and you know we look at
molecular biology we begin to see the
mechanisms behind that kind of tinkering
and repurposing which is you know really
fabulous stuff so I can imagine you know
it might be much harder for that fish to
climb up on the land if it didn't have
fins in the first place or flipped
flippers sort of a flipper like limb
with basic had a shoulder it had an
elbow and had a wrist and I had part of
the of the fin that the terminal end of
the fin that could serve as a palm this
is a fish that can do a push up that can
even walk and funny with and by the way
this fish also had lungs so you can
imagine that these fish with all this
gear living in you know water walking on
the bottom of the water or maybe in the
mud flats it was already set up to jump
into land when when the need happen and
to refine those structures and to modify
them and repurpose them in new ways I
think maybe to the people who are not
experts the fact that it had lungs is
even more impressive and surprising than
the fact that it could develop feet
because as long as you have flippers you
can imagine morphing them into feet but
if you breathe through gills why do you
also have lungs yeah that's great and so
this is actually something that was
discovered in the 1830s we've known this
forever yet you know if you talk to
people they always think well lungs
arose when yeah of course they're
related to you know living on land no
they're not they originally came out and
came about in creatures living in water
and we've known that since Napoleon's
expeditions to Egypt in the early 1800s
and ever since
and what people started to do is they
discovered you know in discectomy kinds
of fish that they saw in Africa or South
America or in Australia they found that
some fish have lungs real lungs that are
exactly like ours in many ways and in
fact if you look at a lot of fish a lot
of fish have a air sac that is connected
to the gut tube or related to the gut
tube in developmental and development
and you know in some of those fish that
sac becomes lungs and others that sac
becomes swim bladder which they use for
buoyancy so this air sac presence in
fish is really ancient and in fact an
air sac that functions as a long as
ancient still so you know what is it
doing well in critter and fish that have
lungs
they have both gills and lungs and more
often than not they're using their gills
they're you know sitting in waters like
an oldish and breathing right but water
the the oxygen concentration in water
can vary a lot it can vary a lot from
month to month season to season and so
forth and so there are times when the
oxygen content of water is not
sufficient to support an animal's life
and what they'll do is that those in
those cases they'll go to the the
surface and actually go up air into
their lungs and then go back down and so
long as they're sort of an accessory
organ that allow fish to exploit water
that has variable oxygen concentrations
throughout the year and there are lots
of strategies that fish have to do this
some have lungs and others breathe
through their skin still others will
vascular eyes parts of their mouth and
use that as a respiratory organ so
there's lots of little different
intentions that happen in evolution to
allow fish to breathe air air breathing
in fish is very very common but lungs
are a very ancient one and so our
distant relatives who originally took
the first steps to walk on land they
didn't need to evolve long so you're
already existing did the look is it safe
to say that the lungs always came from
swim bladders or air sacs or something
like that was there some prior purpose
that are developed yeah safe to say that
the lungs actually originally rose as a
developmentally as an out pocket
the gut - so during development the tube
that forms the gut it develops there and
then it out pockets forms an out pouch
and in some fish that pouch becomes
lungs and others have become swim
bladders so they're related
developmentally but the whole thing is
it's the common developmental process
that gives rise to both and pretty much
all fish have you know one or the other
yeah good and I this is a good segue
thank you for doing my work there
because one of the lessons of your book
is that one of the major sort of
resources for doing this repurposing is
tinkering with our development right
that's right there's this famous but
slightly exaggerated idea that ontogeny
recapitulates phylogeny tell us that
that story a little bit and maybe we can
work salamanders in there at some point
because the salamander stuff was just
amazing yeah it's really cool so you
know ontogeny recapitulates phylogeny a
lot of us learned it in high school I
did I learned it in junior high and he
was like a little jingle we'd all sing
in like you know the third week of
evolution or something like that and
yeah yeah as most people know it's this
notion that that an older notion program
that claims that during the course of
development going from egg to adult you
know through the court different stages
of embryology organisms creatures would
track their evolutionary history so if
you look at a mammal it would go through
a fish stage and amphibian stage reptile
station so forth and this was right
after Darwin you know wrote the Origin
of Species urns tackle great German
biologists really promulgated this
theory pushed it along and there are
other versions of recapitulation as well
there was one that can actually came out
before Darwin and that basically said
that you know creatures look most
similar as embryos they tend to get look
very different as adults that's actually
much more modern concept even though
it's the older one in many anyway these
were very foundational concepts it turns
out that you know the biology is a world
of exceptions particularly for ontogeny
recapitulates phylogeny and there are so
many exceptions you should probably tell
us taj andean phylogeny are yeah sorry
but thanks so ontogeny is another word
for development phylogeny is and never
has another word for
evolutionary history so development you
know tracks evolutionary history that's
recapitulate recapitulates phylogeny
basically means in English development
repeat you know tracks evolutionary
history and so that was a very dominant
theory worldview for a period of time
turns out to be wrong though there are
cases where it does that you know so
there are some cases where we do see in
individual traits that the development
will track evolutionary history but it's
certainly not true as uh sort of a law
of nature like heckle and his
contemporaries proposed it so it does
seem to be true that in the embryos etc
of various species you see features that
are in common with very other with very
very different species presumably
because of our common ancestry that's
correct so you know we see a ton of that
in fact that's we see so much common in
development and that's you know when you
look at an early embryo of a fish and a
human you'll find an enormous number of
similarities in the skull bones and then
in the digestive system in the excretory
system and so forth but it's not like we
track evolutionary history it's just
that we begin from a common stage of
development more or less or our you know
our early stage of development tend to
be much more similar it's kind of the
the idea there but you know then the the
relationship of developments embryology
to evolution has long been a source of
fascination for scientists in my field I
mean it's it's really the embryo has
always held this special place because
you think about it you know here I'm
studying evolutionary history and I'm
looking at great transformations you
know in the history of life but what
happens in development great
transformations like happen every hour
you know right organs appear at it you
know you begin as a single cell and the
cell doubles and doubles and doubles and
doubles and eventually you get germ
layers these different layers that that
form different tissues of the body and
then now heart emerges the central
nervous system emerges these things
emerge over time and part of the
fascination which I felt as a graduate
student you know and when you're looking
at an embryo you're looking at an
organism being built it's a it's a
really beautiful thing and when we can
compare you know
the embryos of different creatures say a
fish and a mammal you begin to see how
you can begin to explain the differences
between them by differences in the way
they're built right and that's a
freaking our 'full way to look at
evolution which reminds me I wanted to
ask a little bit more about the history
of Darwin and this is out of order but
that's okay
you know Darwin correctly gets credit
for natural selection etcetera but there
were ideas floating around that you know
species evolved in some very generalized
sense without necessarily all the
mechanisms of random mutation and
natural selection right oh that's
correct I mean the notions of evolution
were around before Darwin you mentioned
Lamarck he was before Darwin Darwin's
own grandfather Erasmus Darwin had a
notion of evolution and in fact when
Darwin was working on his theory of
evolution other people were coming up
with it at the same time Alfred Russel
Wallace and a few other people you know
independently so yeah the idea has been
out there and in fact many of the ideas
we use in an evolutionary concept
originally came about in before Darwin
so this notion of about embryos being
very similar more similar to one another
than adults that was something that was
pre Darwinian yeah that's just amazing
to me so they already had that idea even
oh yes they were they were really trying
to explain diversity you know some of
them in my new book is trying to explain
diversity how do we how do we know how
do we explain and understand you know
the diversity of life we see on our
planet
right well people have been out after
that for a long time before Darwin
it's just they weren't using natural
selection as a mechanism they saw you
know work of a creator but they were
looking for order and rules that
explained that underneath diversity that
explained it you know in a lot of those
ideas that they developed in the
pre-darwinian context actually apply
very well and evolutionary one did
anyone have the idea that you know God
did it and it was designed but God's
plan involved species changing over time
from something simple to the incredible
diversity we see today the eye
I'm not aware of that particular view
because one of the challenges for that
I'm some some listener probably would
know it I don't however one of the
challenges for that was to accept that
you'd have to accept that species are
imperfect and they go extinct and the
concept of extinction was a relatively
new one in biology believe it or not you
know it has it has its own history but
it really wasn't until soon before
Darwin that people really accepted the
reality of extinction you know so if you
don't have extinction you know and if
species are perfect and then it's hard
to have a notion of evolution and
Soviets the ideas extinction was itself
part and did the understanding of
evolution of an extinction was really an
essential for Darwin and other approach
and other people's perspectives on
evolution as well so there was still
some picture that you know nature was
kind of a perfect kind of setup and
there was no reason for it to change
over time and that was part of the
cultural change that Darwin rode in on
yeah and that was kind of the dominant
worldview and but these folks and many
of them would make it into the book
we're really looking for order and
diversity rules and diversity you know
what explains why a fish looks the way
it does and a human and they were trying
to do it in a in a in a world where
these species are fixed and not changing
but in doing that they devised tools
conceptual tools that we use today and
one of them is this notion called
homology where you know again it has
pre-darwinian roots but it translated
very well for Darwin the idea that you
can compare similar structures and
different species you know that you can
compare a vertebra from a fish to a
reptile you know to a bird to human and
you can compare the same vertebra among
these different things that was a notion
that came up in the pre Darwinian world
but yet you know Darwin basically you
know put a put a mechanistic and
material spin on it basically saying the
reason why you can do that is because
these things share an evolutionary
history right let me pause for a second
to talk about joy bird furniture if
you'd like to customize your life it's
important to customize your home which
means customizing your furniture getting
exactly what you want for your style in
your space joy bird lets you do that
with over 50 different kinds of fabric
and leather
three shades of
in over 250 unique silhouettes you can
put together exactly the kind of
furniture that fits into your lifestyle
you can visit joy Birds Instagram feed
they'll give you a whole bunch of ideas
and inspirations for what's trending
right now whether it's mid-century
modern craftsman boho and so forth you
can get a 365-day home trial skip the
furniture store bring it home sit on it
sleep in it if you don't love your joy
bird return it so you can create
furniture that matches your own fearless
style at joy bird calm / mind scape
that's joy bird calm / mind scape you'll
receive an exclusive offer for 25% off
your first order by using the mindscape
code see how joy bird can help make your
dream space a reality good so this is an
appropriate time to bring in the
salamanders because I think this is just
a wonderful example of how you know
there were there is a connection between
development and evolution
yeah salamanders I love snow so I did
part of my PhD thesis on salamanders I
just love them and then I did my postdoc
I mean I didn't grow up as a kid who
loved you know perps
you know reptiles and amphibians and
stuff but as a graduate student I just
fell in love with these little creatures
and they had just have such a history so
I mean one of my favorite stories is Gus
do Maria who was a professor at the
Museum of the Natural History in Paris
you know he and his dad were experts
académica Domitian experts on reptiles
and amphibians and this is a time of
discovery sort of in the mid late 1800s
right after Darwin about 1864 or so and
so do Morell would get shipments of
critters from expeditions around the
world that folks found and they'd want
him to you know figure it out well one
day he gets a box with I think you know
six Salamon six salamanders inside and
these were from Mexico and he looks in a
box and he the peat folks sent it to him
because Darwin just published his theory
and the salamanders that he was sent
they had an aquatic tail big fleshy
lobed tail
they had external gills they were fully
aquatic and they sent them to do Meriel
thinking while here's a living missing
link right this is kind of like a
creature
that you know maybe will tell us
something about how fish about to walk
on land so um did they know about
salamanders at all in Europe at the time
yes they did yeah because there was
there were there are European
salamanders so they knew quite a bit
about them you know just their local
species but this from Mexico was weird
because I've had this is a giant adult
fully you know full adult with all these
aquatic features so he's like oh this is
great so he um so he put him in his
menagerie and it sounded his reason to
care for you can act leave him alone for
long periods of time and that's exactly
what he did and he came back after a
period of time and he went back to his
box he looked in his box and he saw his
you know fully adult salamanders that
were aquatic with external gills but
then there was a whole nother type of
salamander there fully adult reproducing
big with no external gills a fully
terrestrial body
no it's no kkuk wata quail no external
gills he looked at it's like these are
two different genera okay
something happened in not just disease
yeah yeah it's like there was this was a
magic box well he was a scientist he
didn't follow the magic reasoning so he
said what is going on here something
amazing happened I mean it's almost like
you know he put gorillas in the cage he
came back and found chimps and gorillas
next year I mean it was like that kind
of thing so um so he did is he did his
homework and he started to study their
embryology and he found that this
difference is really a simple shift of
development and it showed how a simple
shift of development can bring about
changes across the entire animal so what
happened is during the normal life cycle
of one of these salamanders you know
they think they have an egg they hatched
from the egg they swim around in water
with external gills and I'm fleshy tails
that are like a fin and then at some
point they're like they swim around this
aquatic larva right and then they get
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and then eventually at some point in
their life they undergo metamorphosis
and at metamorphosis hormone is
triggered thyroid hormone and they lose
the external gills the tail changes the
head changes all that good stuff
and what do Morrell realized as well as
some other people at the time was what
happened in his box is the salamanders
the aquatic salamander is reproduced
but their offspring underwent
metamorphosis which those other ones
didn't and so there was a the trick
there is whether you undergo
metamorphosis or not which can be
triggered by external cues in these
species so it's really remarkable he was
able to show and this is a huge insight
that a subtle change in development
maybe just changing you know thyroid
hormone and metamorphosis can have
changes across the body and two animals
can look entirely different as a result
of that so that work was really
foundational in the sense that what it
did is it turn people Han to thinking
about well what kinds of subtle changes
in development can bring about some of
these huge changes in the history of
life that Darwin was talking about and
it turns out one simple way is just to
change the timing of developmental
events extend development slap it early
that sort of stuff yeah I mean it's
amazing to me because it just just be
super clear that other form that did
undergo the metamorphosis is completely
land-based it doesn't look like it has
any aquatic paraphernalia at all is that
correct that's right that's correct yeah
so I mean the body looks totally
different right and the way it feeds is
totally different the whole thing so and
it's a really just a subtle change in
the level of hormone at one time of
development and also the fact that it
can it can just get stuck in that premed
amorphous this age and still flourish
right it's a perfectly working
salamander but it's an aquatic Islander
and by the way it's really useful if the
critters living in water right so you
know so and think about that here the
whole water land transition happens in
one animal through the course of its yes
and in here I go study fossils look at
this guy but that's really amazing
because you know then then the hunt is
on well what kind of changes to
development can bring about the
evolutionary changes we see yeah and
again it's these changes a timing
developmental then sits now we know it's
a lot of molecular changes and how genes
are controlled turned on and off during
development you know there's an I mean
that's been a that's been such a
powerful and powerfully important
tradition in my field of biology this
relationship between development and
evolution is it's it's own subfield now
yeah
and but I mean you you already now
mentioned something that is crucial to
this story as good as the
19th century was about figuring out all
sorts of weird things about animals
these days we have information about DNA
and genes that is really changing the
whole way we think about this story
that's correct and so the predicate for
all this where people like do Murray oh
who were studying the embryos who are
studying the bodies but the game changer
for us is really the advent of molecular
biology you know and it and it's it in
its power to explain and and it gives us
a whole new set of tools to approach
these classic questions you know and
some of the biggest discoveries started
well they again they have predicates as
well but the 1980s and 1990s were quite
a remarkable time where molecular tools
were getting powerful enough and cheap
enough and could be applied to a number
of different species that we began to
see the relationships between genes and
development in the embryo you know how
genes control that development and how
changes to genes can bring about changes
to development and ultimately changes to
evolution so that has been incredibly
important and incredibly powerful and in
and some of those initial discoveries
were game changers for me in my own
growth as a scientist I had you know I
trained to be a paleontologist and I was
studying how to find fossils
you know the techniques that led to the
discovery of Tiktaalik right mm-hm
but I remember back in the 80s there are
a bunch of papers for being published
and I was made aware of them by a fellow
graduate student and showing that we
were seeing in flies genes that build
the bodies of these animals genes that
control where why a wing is in one part
of the body and an antenna is in another
part of the body and that was exciting
enough but was even more exciting was
later papers showing that not these
chains aren't present only in flies but
versions of these same genes are present
in salamanders frogs yeah worms mice and
people you know that there's a common
toolkit versions of the same genes are
doing similar things in many different
created creatures and and for me that
was a glimmers of a new biology and for
a lot of people it was glimmers of a new
biology in the 80s and and so that's
when I decided to add the molecular
biology toolkit
my own repertoire you know as a
scientist and we don't think that that's
convergent evolution we think this is
just a set of genes that have been with
us a long time oh my gosh yeah these are
ancient genes and these ancient genes
aren't the same but they were you know
they evolved you know in the distant
past of animal life and then you know
there have been rounds of where these
genes have been duplicated modified
repurposed just like structures genes
are repurposed you know and so the these
rules we see for the evolution of
Anatomy they apply very well to the you
know the tinkering the repurposing the
co-option the duplication all these
things that we see in the evolution of
structures they happen at the level of
genes you know so these genes are
ancient but they've also witnessed a lot
of changes though you know flies have
only one set of these genes we have four
so they've been duplicated over time
they've they've gained new functions
more complexity over time that kind of
thing I do I'm sure that the 80s and 90s
were great but I don't want to skip over
like all the really charming early
technologies that were there for
thinking and measuring genes and their
differences and so forth I mean yeah I
guess I'll let you pick your favorite
stories from the book but the idea of
like putting little molecules in a gel
and pulling them across with an
electromagnetic field to see how heavy
they were because I think that these
days were spoiled and people probably
think well just you know look at the DNA
and figure out what it says but they
didn't have that ability back then one
of my favorite stories is Susumu Ohno
Ohno was a researcher at the City of
Hope California and he was interested in
genetics hugely interested in genetics
and his because he would he loved horses
and he found he couldn't train you know
that there's only so much you can train
horses he said it of course is no good
it's no good it's all about the genes so
because of that love of horses and his
knowledge of them he decided to study
genes right and so he designed for the
greatest techniques so he he looked at
chromosomes right chromosomes sit in the
nucleus and right chromosomes or you
know bundles of DNA and he wanted to see
you know can he characterize differences
among species by looking at differences
of their chromosomes right this is in
the 40s and 50s and you know he didn't
have much technology
you know at his at his fingertips what
he had was a microscope I need a camera
and he could develop pictures with that
camera so what he did was he took
pictures of like of different species
they took a salamanders he took rhinos
he took people he would just get cells
right cell samples from the zoo's and
and he would look at the nuclei and look
at the the chromosomes in the nuclei so
we take pictures of all these things and
what he did was lowest technology
possible he took pictures of the
chromosomes printed out the pictures cut
them out and weighed them so he would
basically take pictures of the
chromosomes of a salamander cut them out
and weigh them and then take pictures of
the chromosomes of a human cut them out
and weigh them and he used those weights
as proxy for the amount of DNA in the
cell better make a zoom was the same in
both pictures right yeah well what he
found was that the salamanders have like
10 times more genes chromosomal stuff
than humans and he was one of the first
persons using this low-tech technique to
show that the amount of genetic material
in the nucleus and when we know now is
the amount of you know DNA in the genome
is unrelated to the complexity of the
organism yeah I was gonna say that's not
possible because aren't we like way more
superior to these little salamanders how
their body length in a millisecond some
of these things so that's pretty
superior depends how you measure it but
yeah I mean we're much more complicated
in a lot of ways cognitively and so
forth and yeah he found that that's
unrelated to the amount of genetic
material in the cell so he was one of
the first people to show that you know
the amount of genetic material in a cell
is unrelated to a critters complexity
you know he looked at plants like lilies
they have an enormous amount of that
yeah so that was a huge surprise and
then he was able to look at those
chromosomes because you can you can had
die to the nucleus and like you could
begin to see the chromosomes little
stripes on them he began to see when he
looked in detailed the stripes
looked like whole sections of stripes
were just like repeated and duplicated
like somebody took a Xerox machine to
the chromosome of a salamander just
duplicated whole chunks of it so he came
up with the notion of with all the
low tech technology stuff that the idea
was that perhaps one of the major
sources of innovation for new genetic
material and evolution is gene
duplication is duplicating old genes so
that's that's a great way of you know
co-opting and repurpose repurposing and
so that turns out to be a pre very
profound discovery because the more we
look at gene sequences we can now
sequence genes in an afternoon
you know we begin to see just how
important that is that you know there
are whole gene families you know which
might contain hundreds of genes you know
all related all relate to each other by
history rounds of duplication in their
history I mean I see that tissue and
tissue or you know over and over again I
just love that story because here's a
person who had a great idea found a very
low-tech way to test it and opened up a
whole new field of research ya know it
gives hope for you know the ingenuity of
scientists and and and interesting just
speculate about hell will be equally
ingenious in the years to come hope but
good so let's let's let's get down to
brass tacks about the genes and how they
work I mean so we assume we know the
basic story but an important part of
your the story detail and some assembly
required is that of course we have genes
that is to say we have segments of our
DNA the code for proteins and then the
proteins go and do useful things in our
body but then there's other parts of the
DNA that are regulating when the genes
are switched on and switched off and and
there's also junk DNA and how does all
that fit together and how does it play
into this story of major transitions
okay so I'm just to just to set the
stage right so you know DNA sits in the
nucleus of all of ourselves right and in
each cell there's about six feet so if
you have a strand of DNA it's about if
you were to unwind it it's about six
feet long you know sitting inside the
nucleus so it's been a super tightly
think about that you know you need about
four trillion cells so if you know if
you put all our DNA and end you know if
all our cells stretched it out and laid
a tendon and it would go almost to Pluto
right so that's just and just think
about just how much genetic material is
in our bodies and how tightly packed it
is in each cell it's kind of
mind-blowing now when we think of jeans
when we think of DNA right the DNA is a
sequence of basis right so it's a gene
sequence sits in a double helix it's
packed really tightly you know so
there's a part of the DNA that makes
product contains the information to make
a protein right that's that's the
protein coding part but there's a whole
other sex parts of this that does other
things some of which we don't even we're
still grappling with but to give you a
little perspective the gene part of our
genome right that part that makes
proteins is only 2% of our genome well
so genes only make up about 2% of our
genome so the protein coding part the
part that contains the information to
make the proteins is just a tiny
fraction of the genome the rest of it
kind of controls the activity of those
things is that is that completely true
or is is it's also true that some of it
is just kind of wasted space it could be
yeah it could be wasted space or it
could be space we don't know this
function yet see a lot of the a lot of
the activity of DNA is related to its
dynamism how it opens and closes forms
loops and own itself and so those spacer
regions could have lots of importance in
terms of the overall geometry of the DNA
but the individual sequence might not
matter as much you know okay that's but
there's still a bit of a mistress so
quite a mystery for son boy there's a
lot of inks built on debates around that
yep so but you know you think about this
way if you take us the cells in our body
pretty much all have the same DNA inside
them what's different is they're making
different proteins so the cells in our
and the retina of our eye compared to
the cells are in the skin of our
fingertip you know they have the same
DNA inside them but the DNA in the
retina cells is making proteins that you
know builds and keeps a retina
functioning the cells inside the tip of
our finger you know they're they have
the same DNA but the genes that are
active are the ones making the the skin
tissues right proteins that make skin
give skin tissue it's its properties so
what's different here is which genes are
turned on and off in each kind of cell
in each kind of tissue so it's not the
DNA per se that's utterly different it's
what's what's controlling their activity
so people have really since the I'd say
the mid-late a
he's really focused on that what are
these genetic switches what controls
whether a gene is turned on and off and
you know once we know that is that a big
player in evolutionary change and it
turns out yes yes and yes that's
understanding these switches this is so
important not only to understand what
makes tissues different in health and
disease but also to understand evolution
to say well you know it's not like you
have a new you know protein coding gene
if you have the same gene it's just
you're turning on and off in different
places in different times in development
you know so it all comes back to
development and what these genes are
doing in development and if you're
turning on genes and carrying them off
in different times and places you can
make really big changes right I mean is
it possible to explain to us at the
molecular biology level how the
information encoded in one set of gene
in one side of the DNA actually does
turn on and off the other sets of DNA
yeah so what you have is a bunch of them
so you have the you have the gene a
protein coding gene and lying next to it
is usually a little sequence that when
something attaches to that sequence some
very important things attach to that
sequence it'll turn the gene on or turn
it off depending on you know what the
nature that that little section is so it
all comes down to sort of molecular keys
that come in so basically one part of
the genome might fold over to touch that
switch and when if it does that it
activates the gene so there are lots of
little triggers that would control these
things but you have to think about this
is a very dynamic chemical landscape
where chemicals are being a proteins and
other other factors are being made and
as they do that they're attaching to
these different sorts or switch
sequences in the genome which then
controlled the activity of the gene so
it's three-dimensional structure you
have the you have the you have the
genome opening and closing so when the
genome is closed it's not making protein
since you know sort of open up in areas
where proteins will made so first has to
open up so there's that dynamism of the
genome then certain sections have to
come in and touch these switches
actually connect to them to activate the
genes so there's a whole so Rube
Goldberg kind of set of activities that
have to happen
for a gene to turn on does the
one-dimensional structure change differ
from one kind of cell to the other it
can yeah very much so and so in fact
that's a very active field of research
right now in molecular biology is
understanding this three dimensional
changes and it's really come it's really
gotten very big is is now we can see the
genome we could begin to map it we begin
to see it at work and it's you know what
surprises everybody is just how utterly
dynamic it is and how very important
this three-dimensional structure really
is and there's lots of mysteries here we
don't there's a lot we don't understand
and because it's it's it's filled with
puzzles but one thing we do understand
is just you know how these changes can
affect evolution and that is pretty
clear that is if you you know you change
the switch you're gonna change the you
know ability to make up a new you'll be
able to make some new things in
evolution they're new tissue new protein
and so forth and that fits in with the
connection with development because
obviously development is all about
deciding which kind of cell I'm gonna be
and where I'm going to fit in and and
therefore what kind of what parts of my
DNA are gonna be useful that's right and
you know it's basically it's in if you
think about you know the the genome of
an organism it's basically forming a
recipe for development you know you're
changing the ingredients you can change
the genes you can change the process
which is these switches and what you do
is subtle changes to these things in the
embryo can have large consequences you
know to Anatomy to evolutionary history
just like we saw with the salamanders
and so what we can now do is look at
that at the genetic level so does this
help explain some features of major
transitions I mean does it make it
easier to understand how major
transitions can happen once we
understand this picture of certain
coding areas of the DNA and other
regulatory or expressive regions of the
DNA oh very much so it can show for
instance and it's kind of getting back
to one of the the themes we talked about
earlier with the fossil record is that
you really don't have to often event
whole new things to have great
transitions happen you know a lot of
great transitions might not involve as
much you know new genes as it would
involve using old genes in new ways
right so using genes that exist but
you're changing when and where they're
active so again it's like kind of the
you know the
raw material for these transitions
exists before the transitions themselves
you have the genes just using them in
new ways that's part of it there are
cases where lots of new genes come about
but using old genes and new ways turns
out to be a very profound part of these
great transitions we see that over and
over again the other thing that is
getting renewed attention which is
really fascinating and we see this over
and over again we see this in the you
know the origin of new biological
inventions but we also see it in the you
know the human technological realm is
that one thing that's very common is
multiples that is you'll see the same
call called evolutionary invention
appear independently in different
species at the same time that is the
same solution to a problem appears
independently you know in different
creatures that are not directly related
to one another so it means that's
happened separately and one of the
reasons why that may happen is if
organism if creatures have the same set
of genes functioning the same ways it
makes similar outcomes more likely right
so this notion that you can have
parallel evolution or independent
evolution of the same structure it's
something that's gaining renewed
intention from the molecular realm
because if organisms have similar genes
and they're using those genes in similar
ways then they may not produce then they
might produce the same kinds of
mutations independently that natural
selection can work on because they're
building now and of some some sort of
common starting point they're not too
astray like you say not just randomly
choosing crazy things that's right if
you have a recipe to build cupcake
cupcakes
you know there's only certain ways you
can change that recipe right and have it
still be recognizably cupcakes so yeah
and you hit upon the same you know if
different people are making cupcakes
through the same recipe and and and
playing with in different ways that they
may come up with the same kind of
cupcakes independently so this helps
explain certain examples of convergent
evolution it does very much though
convergent evolution can happen for lots
of reasons
so first is you know and a very common
reason is you know common adaptive
solution you know if creatures are going
to fly they're gonna need some sort of
wing right and you know you see that
over and over again and you see you know
white color patterns appearing
independently and polar animals that
kind of stuff but the other reason why
these sorts of that pattern may happen
is again common recipes common you know
common genes that sort of come recipe
to build bodies common genes that sort
of thing and and does it help explain
this puzzle that's always there in
evolution what I think of as the
statistical mechanics of mutations like
most mutations are presumably really bad
most are not so good but you know you
don't doesn't take many to many
beneficial ones to really take off you
know so a beneficial mutation can gain
traction very very readily but you know
we talk about mutation being random it's
really not random right it's you know
it's it's only random with respect to
like predicting the future I mean it's
like you know just because a creature
may need to walk on land in 100 million
years doesn't mean it's going to come up
with mutations to do that so you know so
it's it's non-random with respect to the
needs of the organism in the future
right but I mean it's random but strict
to the excuse me it's you know it's
random with respect to that but it's not
random with respect to oh you know
certain mutations are more common than
others based on what happens in the
genome certain mutations are more likely
to be beneficial than others based on
what happens in the genome and in
development you know so yeah so when we
talk about random it has to be very
specific about it it's random respect to
predicting the future it's not random
well you talk in the book about the idea
of hopeful monsters and how they kind of
got you in trouble as a graduate student
my trouble with her and Samara in a very
big way yeah really so I used to have
teams so one of the great gigs of my
graduate student life was I don't know
how this happened I was not a great guy
but Meyer took a shine Amir its Meyers
it's great eminence and you know the new
synthesis of evolutionary biology was
huge eminency was about in his mid 80s
at the time is very old and had a lot of
history and he loved history science and
philosophy of science and he was there
during one of the pivotal you know times
in our field and for some reason took a
shine I mean he used to invite me for
Thursday teas up into his office on the
fifth floor of the Museum of Comparative
Zoology at Harvard and I you know made
the pilgrimage there every mmm every
Thursday you know and I was up in the
bird collection it smelled like
mothballs and
old creaky floors and Meyer would you
know sit in this chair and just wax
about great people in the field and he
always encouraged me to come with a
a book a paper a question to stimulate
it so I came one day with this book
called the material basis of evolution
which is a recent reprint it had an
introduction by Steve Gould that just
came out like you know a couple weeks
before a month before and I brought it
up to Mayer say buddy look at this new
thing what do you think of gold's
preface and he just turned beet red and
shot me this glare like kid I'm gonna
rate you he went to his filing cabinet
came back with this papers I wrote
animal species in evolution in response
to page 95 of this piece of crap and he
threw it down at me this this this
yellowed reprint by Goldschmidt which
laid out the theory that you can have
you know major evolutionary transitions
in one step in one mutation so-called
macro mutations now I knew coachmen was
a bit of a whipping boy at the time but
I wanted to talk to Mayer about you know
what he thought about it was I think oh
boy yeah I was just with something else
so this is so-called Smith's idea that
one that got me so in trouble with Mayer
oh by the way the tease did continue the
contentious place Harvard evolutionary
biology right oh I'm sorry the Harvard
evolutionary biology seems like a
famously contentious place they were big
it was yeah Wilson and Steve cooled at
the time Richard Lou Anton Mayer yes I
had to navigate that a little bit anyway
so um I did so pretty much unscathed
anyway so um the idea was that you
coachman proposed he studied development
ran a study genes he said look subtle
changes in development can yield big
effects so hey the first bird hatched
out of a reptile egg he said basically
one mutation you know once the new
mutations you got a bird out of a
reptile and you know that was not
well-received for good reason and there
are a lot of reasons why that theory was
but it's it's it's reappeared in
different ways over the years but
there's it really is not not a very
viable theory that despite the fact that
you know you you can't find mutations
that will do big things to the animal it
turns out that those big mutations are
almost exclusively you know lethal it's
really the small mutations that
our most likely to be beneficial so it's
the accumulation of these so that sorry
that is the current way of thinking that
in fact it is the accumulation of tiny
things that is much more yeah yeah
driving the engine of evolution yeah
yeah but and that but that accumulation
could have happened pretty quickly right
over geological timescales it does you
know it's you know the geological
timescales I deal with are in the
millions hundreds of thousands to
millions to tens of millions of years
yeah you know we're talking about these
accumulation of these mutations can
happen much much much faster than that
particularly in knowing ways that genome
can change well it's gonna ask this
about the you know issue of missing
links when you've begun such a
transition you know there's no teleology
you're not aiming for some target but
once you've sort of been able to enter a
slightly different ecological niche is
it true that then the rate of evolution
is faster for species like you than
those that are happily in their
equilibrium and therefore there are
fewer records of those in the fossils oh
it's an interesting point so um there
are cases where creatures enter a new
zone like ecological zone and the
evolutionary rate takes off but there
are other cases where it's it's a
delayed fuse where something happens and
that diversification you know the
explosives ERISA fication doesn't happen
so much later and we really don't know
why that happens that's a bit of a
puzzle you know why you might have that
yeah so I that's that's still very much
an open question okay I always like to
you know give the undergrads and
graduate students out there in the
audience
problems to work on so that sounds it's
always good to find the open questions
oh we got lots of those well and so
there's also you already mentioned this
I think very briefly but let's link it
back in here now that we're talking
about the transitions at the molecular
level the idea of genes jumping from one
animal to another and being borrowed
right like he tells stories of how
viruses virus genes got embedded in
other people's genes I think this is
something obviously that is not part of
the classic story of molecular biology
and evolution no it's amazing so like
when you look at it like a human genome
sequence we've sequenced yeah we could
sequence genomes now pretty quickly
right when you look at a gene sequence
what you
mind is in humans about almost 10% about
8 percent of our genome of our entire
genome are defunct viruses viruses that
viral sequences that no longer function
you know but they're there it's like a
fossil graveyard you know a graveyard of
of ancient viruses that that attacked
our genome became part of our genome but
then got got knocked out every time the
biologists it's very important they
creep out the audience at some point or
and you know think about its gets even
creepier still when you think that ok
only 2% of our genomes are our genes you
know but a percent or like the for
viruses yeah but there's also something
else that's really amazing about these
so viruses are can as we know as is very
relevant in today's world viruses are
can we live it in a balance with viruses
right they're continually infecting us
and our internal mechanisms whether it's
our immune system our genome are trying
to knock them out are trying to disable
them but there's something else that's
happening as well and this is something
that's pretty new and it begins with
there was a researcher when I talk about
in the book
Jason Shepard at the University of Utah
he's you know he's neurobiology it's
nitrogen viruses here's an MD though he
studied his microbiology but he's
interested in memory you know and his
research and memory led him to a gene
called arc AR see because arc is a gene
that is involved in memory and people
mutations in that car and associate with
dementia schizophrenia mutations in arc
and mice mean that they lose their
memories they can't they can do a maze
but the next day they forget their
solution and so he's studying arc that's
this thing right and because he wants to
he cares about neurodegenerative
diseases and memory any studying
arkanese studying when you study a gene
you're gonna study its protein so he
looks at the protein that arc made and
he pops it in a microscope after some
some effort hi turns out he saw these
spheres these cereals and he's like
looking at I'm thinking I start I seen
these cereals before I you know in his
microbiology class in medical school
that's those the capsules that look like
the virus
HIV the virus that causes AIDS there's a
wait a minute it looks more like a virus
than a memory protein so he runs down
them to the next building to talk to
people AIDS experts doesn't tell them
what is on the slide says identify this
for me
these AIDS experts look at the HIV
experts look at the slide and they say
oh that's you know HIV the virus causes
a new arc memory gene in people what do
you not religious bearing gifts
yeah so what happens is what Jason
Shepard showed in his lab and some
others as well
is that what arc is is this an ancient
virus that invaded a distant ancestor of
people and that virus instead of being
knocked out by the genome it was
domesticated it was repurposed it was
like sorry you got a new job you're no
longer going to infect us you're gonna
make a protein that's gonna be used in
memory and the read what's relevant here
is that capsule that is made by HIV and
arc helps the information the genetic
that capsules made to protect the the
genetic information of the virus as it
goes from cell to cell so it makes HIV
very effective and going from cell to
cell but that's exactly what makes the
arc gene effective in making memories it
goes from neuron and neuron so the so
this virus was put to work which is
repurposed if you will by our distant
anthea the genome of our distant
ancestors just how we don't know but it
was to play a role in memory and we're
finding that in all kinds of other genes
too in genes that make the placenta they
the proteins that make the placenta some
of those genes were originally viruses
that invaded the genome it's also
purposing this whole evolution never
does its repurpose yeah it's either take
something from something else and
repurpose it or repurpose your own
genome and you know it's mergers and
acquisitions it's claiming things as
well as your own yeah and so it's a wild
world but you know these viruses are not
only threats but they're sources of
genetic information genetic novelty
there's sources of new genetic stuff
that occasionally have made a very big
difference in our evolutionary history
and that's one thing that you know
within the last decade has become you
know under you know under much clearer
focus and it's pretty really remarkable
and we should probably distinguish
because probably many people of her
the story that you relate in the book
about Lynn Margulis and mitochondria
right and so forth and that's sort of we
absorbed little tiny organisms and made
them part of ourselves but mitochondria
have separate DNA this is what we're
talking about now is actually sticking
segments of virus DNA into our DNA
strands right yeah so what a virus does
right there there are lots of different
kinds of viruses so there's many
different ways that this happens but you
know typically a virus will enter and
then it you know goes into the the
genome of its host and then commandeer
is the genome to make more copies of
itself
you know it's like the ultimate parasite
right yeah it goes in there makes copies
of itself takes it over takes over the
machinery makes more copies of itself
and you know there it goes so what
happens is sometimes the host can take
over the virus or knock off the virus
but also take it over to do new things
and that's what we're seeing in some of
these cases so the viruses can be the
source of genetic novelty right yeah as
well yeah and I don't know how much you
followed the controversies over at what
point do we stop calling this star
Whitney and evolution I mean obviously
you know Darwin said a lot of true
things and then there was this new
synthesis with genetics and so forth but
the idea that we simply you know do
sexual reproduction and some of our DNA
base pairs get mutated but otherwise we
just hand them on is way oversimplified
right and so at what point do we call it
a new theory versus just weeks on the
old view think about when Darwin did
though
Darwin largest species the first edition
was 1859 right there was no knowledge of
genetics what so ever yeah okay we
didn't know anything ever Mendelian come
till much later let alone a knowledge of
DNA yet that theory he proposed before
genetics kind of didn't make sense under
the kind of inheritance that they
thought then yeah so in fact some of the
most you know trenchant criticisms of
Darwin were about that you know that and
I without a not there was no knowledge
of genetics with no knowledge of you
know heredity it was really hard to
think about how these changes could be
sustained over time
though he did use artificial selection
or if she's breeding experiments as well
in this innocent ISM it is argument but
it's a good point yeah we have moved far
beyond but we're staying very much in
the center of Darwin natural selection
is still the major mechanism of
evolution common descent is still the
major pattern we see in the history of
life albeit with some exceptions where
you have information being traded among
species um you know that when we talk
about Darwin we're really talking about
not just a body a theory but a profound
shift the Darwinian revolution was a
profound shift in the way we see the
natural world how it came about and our
relationship to it so when we think
about you know search Darwinian biology
I kind of refer to it and those in those
ways in terms of you know the fruits of
the Darwinian revolution yeah yes and no
we're still using some of Darwin's ideas
I mean one of the main ideas in the book
is actually a Darwinian one the idea of
repurposing the idea that you know
structures arise in one form originally
and then they changed function later on
but it's just amazing to me I read the
book I did a deep dive back into several
of the editions of Darwin different
editions in in preparation for writing
some assembly required and I was struck
by so many things I was struck by what a
great way he was able to marshal
evidence how he used it what a great
writer he was you know not only and
provide producing evidence but some of
his prose is just really beautiful I
just would sit there and read it over
and over again or just some amazing
stuff he just what a remarkably talented
human being yeah we're lucky because of
that right because not all scientists
are like that but he did have the ideas
and was able to convey them in an
especially compelling poetic way so
that's nice yeah so beautiful it really
is at every level the intellectual level
as well as the aesthetic one yeah all
right so I think that we're able to get
some pay off here so all this
understanding of genes and and and
expression and regulation and so forth
tell us how this explains how fish can
develop hands well I mean my lab works
on that and yes we never know we don't
in the summer we go out to find fossils
and the rest of the year we're working
on the DNA of extant fish so you know
working on mice people were able to
identify a series of genes and
regulatory elements elements that
control
the activity of those genes that are
deeply involved in making wrists and
fingers and nice people and everything
that has wrists and fingers right and
you can identify those genes and you
know when they showed for instance that
if you say make a mouse lacking these
genes the mouse has a radio a humerus a
radius and ulna but no wrist in digits
if you mark the cells that you know that
where these genes are active they're in
the wrists and the digits so these genes
are wrist and digit genes they're
necessary for the wrist and digit not
necessarily sufficient there are
probably other ones as well but the but
they're necessary so my lab as well as a
bunch of others have asked the question
are these genes present in fish the
answer is yes we've known that for a
while and if so are these genes involved
in fish fin development and again if so
what are they doing in fish offenses yes
we've been looking well turns out make a
very long story short this is like a ten
year research program of my lab longer
than Tiktaalik actually huh the search
for Tiktaalik that was six years this is
ten but the the central idea is that
many of the genes that make the wrists
and digits of mice and people and birds
and so forth our precedent fish and
they're making a terminal strip of
tissue in those fins and that terminal
strip of tissue gives rise to the fin
raise those you know the spicules of
bone that you see like if you look at a
trout when you look at its fins it looks
clear and the terminal end of the fin
with little rays inside their little
bony rod it makes those rods and so
what's remarkable here is that there is
a common tool kit to make appendages as
different as mouths as people mice and
fish fins and limbs that those genes are
there that they're active and that in
all species they're active in making the
terminal end of them of the fin what's
different is there's a switch in fish
that turns those cells where those genes
are active into fin rays whereas in us
and mice and others it makes makes it
makes makes fingers and toes so
what we're able to see is that there's a
common history genetic history of limbs
and fins and that the differences among
them aren't as much in you know entirely
new genes but it's using in in in in
using those genes in new ways and and
and modifying their activity in
different ways so it's there's a case
where molecular biology has given us
insights that we might not have had
otherwise because if I was just looking
at Anatomy
I would never compare fingers and toes
with the fin raise fish right but
there's a clear-cut developmental
connection between them and so now what
we're doing and some other labs are
looking at okay well what controls
whether you have a finger or a thin ray
you know what are the molecular controls
that control that you how you make those
different kinds of tissues so as we open
the whole thing is it's you know when
you have answers like we had with this
research now we can ask whole new kinds
of powerful more precise questions you
know so it's so these these answers now
set us up but for a whole new set of
experiments which we're doing now and
you go in is this by going in and
zapping some of the genes to kill them
off or keep them get longer or and
seeing what kind of organism results
yeah so what we'll do is we could take
the genes from a mouse and put them in a
fish and you can see what they do we
could take the fish genes and put them
in a mouse and see what they do in that
in that new environment turns out they
function very well I could take a shark
gene from the fin and put it in a mouse
some of these genes from a shark and put
him into a mouse and it does perfectly
fine likewise the mouse one in the shark
so we can make these swaps we can also
knock these genes out we can use CRISPR
cast genome editing you know go in there
and just knock these genes out and
delete them we can add factors as well
so yeah it's a real you know house of
horrors here we could do it all but what
it shows is quite literally that you
know that there is a deep connection
among creatures that you know nothing is
more I still find it amazing that we
could take a fish gene and put it in a
mouse and it functions just fine you
know in the in the limb of a mouse you
know where he isn't a fish it works in
this fin that in a nutshell just shows
you just the deep connections among you
know all life on our planet are you a
fan of the sci-fi channels
TV show shark to puss I think that
should be your next yeah I'm surprised
they didn't call me to consult well I
mean let's you know we're at the end of
the podcast here so now we can let our
hair down and speculate a little bit we
learned a lot about how major
transitions happen in real evolution
your opening I don't want to call it
Pandora's box but at least a whole door
onto a new landscape of things where we
can make major revolutions in our labs
like is this going to be a frontier over
the next hundred years where we're I
mean not just figuring out how evolution
happened but designing organisms for
human purposes oh I mean I think you
know it's already happening right I mean
you have people growing organs and
dishes you know tissue tissue
engineering for clinical purposes as
well you know we already have people who
use computation and a knowledge of
evolutionary history to resurrect
proteins that were present 400 million
years ago and tests their activity know
we can reconstruct ancestors at least at
the biochemical level we can modify
development at the embryo logical and
developmental level in the genetic level
as well and we can begin to you know
mimic in certain stages of evolution
that sometimes sometimes that's helpful
sometimes it's not but we're definitely
in this brave new world where we can
manipulate things as well the big game
changer has been obviously genome
editing that CRISPR cash gene editing
which applies to so many species it's
remarkably effective but it's also
remarkably cheap you know so like this
is important when you're in a big lab
and that
yeah and that's that's been a huge
game-changer for us I mean I have a
colleague here at Chicago Joe Thornton
who is literally resurrecting ancient
proteins to understand how enzymes
originally came about and he uses you
know knowledge of evolutionary history
and computation to make predictions
about what those proteins looked like
and then he makes them in the lab and
test their activity and we can tweak
genes right now to test can we make a
limb bone in a fish fin I have a
colleague from Harvard who who did just
that with a mutant he found and showed
that you know fish fins have the ability
to make limb like bones you know so
really remarkable stuff it's a
definitely a brave new world yeah
so the answer is yes we will be seeing I
mean it's just the beginning of all this
and people will talk about regulating it
and so forth but my rough feeling is
that once you can do something someone
out there is gonna do it and so remix in
all sorts of organisms and their organs
is is going to be a major frontier I
think so I know with a little drive it
obviously would be clinical you know
making new kinds of tissues that can
help in regeneration regeneration is a
big thing too from being able to rebuild
organs to you and that's that's people
are pushing the limits of that as well
well okay so for the very last question
with let's return a little bit back to
reality we talked about how fins can
turn into hands and so forth but the
other obvious question is human beings
right we're very similar to other
primates but we do have these big brains
I recently saw a claim which then I
think I saw people arguing against but
the claim was that there are mental
capacities cognitive capacities that
chimpanzees are much better at than we
human beings you know short term memory
kinds of tasks and the claim was that we
have I don't say intentionally but we
have sacrificed that part of our
cognitive capacities in order to develop
language and linguistic capacities is
it's this kind of trade-off a big part
of what turns other primates into we
smart and sexy human beings that but
trade-offs are a very huge part of of
human history right there's trade-offs
in terms of the structure of our brain
there's trade-offs in terms of the
structure of our general system our
ability to walk the trade-offs of just
being human are huge because there are
costs to him to being human we suffer
certain kinds of to conditions that are
that are not seen another another
creatures you know our ability to talk
for instance I'm just shifting it from
the cognitive piece because I know less
about that honestly but the our ability
to talk comes at a huge trade-off so it
wouldn't
Smith at cognitive issues do as well so
for instance you know we are the only
animals that suffer a certain or
particular kind of dangerous sleep apnea
and the reason for that is we have a
very flexible back of our throat that's
and the instead of neural circuits that
play a huge role in our ability to make
sounds so our ability to make sounds for
language comes at a giant cost because
it sets us up for certain kinds of sleep
apnea which are which can be quite quite
dangerous but that's true for almost
every part of human the human body I
mean whether it's our walking on two
legs whether it's having huge brains
that can seem am enormous amount of
energy whether it's having cognitive
capacities to make language that are
trade-offs from other kinds of cognitive
capacities which we might have had you
know trade-offs are a part of being an
extreme organism like we are we're
highly optimized in certain ways and
that optimization comes at a cost you
know because of the the inherent nature
of trade-offs I mean I guess I already
said this is last question so I lied but
I just had a podcast with Martin Rees
where we talked a little bit about the
prospects for post humanity and how you
know in different environments and so
forth we might evolve in different ways
like people living on Mars might have
skeletal structures or something like
that is it
for evolutionary biologists or people in
teams
there are things we could improve here
are things that we could intentionally
tune that make us better like you know
get rid of back aches or something like
that oh yeah definitely I mean there's I
mean in fact our relationship to the
microbial world we can change you know
we you and you think about we're just
beginning to come to grips with our
relationship to the microbial world and
that relationship can sometimes hurt us
but oftentimes it's in most of the times
it's essential for our lives and that's
something that you know as we look
forward that's something that is going
to be incredibly important to think
about but no I mean just you can look at
all any part of our body that they
didn't say well geez that's something
that that needs to change going forward
but a lot depends on the operative
environment that we find ourselves
living in you know so the environment
today yeah you could say certainly that
you know there are certain aspects of
our bodies that in this modern
environment that we're kind of
disconnected from you know we have an
evolutionary history in one environment
yeah you know many of us are living in
you know in in built environments now
yeah that are very different and we have
a sedentary lifestyle so our whole
metabolism is sort of ill-equipped to
you know we are we evolved from a highly
active you know ancestors and we're and
most of us are kind of relatively said
and less active you uh when you think
about the leading cause of death you
know cardiovascular disease cancers and
so forth these are all parts of the
trade off of being human and living in
our modern world right and so I could
think of all host of things that would
need to change you know we are
susceptible of all kinds of cancers and
that are a product of living in our
modern world and that product of living
you know after 50 and so yeah I can I
could give you a list of many things to
change based on where we're living now
and I can give you in a longer list if
you know you're telling me we're going
to be living in basis and Mars or
terraforming somewhere or whatever well
good it's good it's good to know that
you know we're members of the last
generation of purely organic human
beings one part iPhone actually you're
born organically VD rated over time all
right Neil Shubin thanks that was a
fascinating conversation thanks for
being on the podcast thanks for having
me appreciate